g le procès dit ce réquisitoire
aujourd'hui l'avocat général n'a réclamé
ni peine ni condamnation
mais sans demander clairement
l'acquittement sur place dominique
verdeilhan frédéric bohn assurément
l'avocat général à l'art du suspense
durant plus de trois heures il manie le
chaud et le froid
trois pas en avant deux en arrière
tantôt un réquisitoire contre patrick
dils tantôt un réquisitoire contre
francis paul les aveux répétés de deal
ce gène le magistrat ils sont
insoutenables inhumain dévastateur un
souci d'abondance du détail angoissant
ce n'était pas la peine de rajouter
martèle l'avocat général francis heaulme
troubles inévitablement le magistrat
c'est certes un élément nouveau dit-il
mais pas suffisant
lance-t-il en direction de la défense
une démonstration méticuleuse mais qui
débouche sur une impasse innocents
coupables
l'avocat général a un doute il le soumet
aux jurés sens prononcé une seule fois
le mot acquittement
stupéfaction des parties civiles
l'avocat général qui certainement dû
fréquenter
l'école des jésuites n'a pas voulu
prendre franchement position à balancer
et a essayé de suggérer dans ce dossier
il ya beaucoup de suggestions ont
réessayé de suggérer ses doutes
le religieux prend le pas sur le
judiciaire après jésuites la défense et
votre compte pilates
je maintiens l'expression ponce pilate
mais je sais d'un réquisitoire qui est
très judiciairement correct ça évite de
faire de la peine aux parties civiles et
si on est là c'est la faute du vilain
disent impossible ce soir de mesurer
l'impact de ce doute de ce réquisitoire
sur les 15 jurés lyonnais à reims
l'avocat général avait requis
l'acquittement en 40 minutes
douze heures plus tard le verdict tombe
et 25 ans de réclusion criminelle